- [Narrator] When billionaire
Elon Musk bought Twitter,
some Tesla investors
worried Musk was abandoning
the electric vehicle maker
to focus on the social media company.
(Musk laughing)
- So in Twitter...
- What could possibly go wrong?
(all laughing)
- [Narrator] Since the deals
closed in late October,
Tesla shares have slipped
ending the year down 65%.
The company's worst year on record.
But the reason for the selloff
goes far beyond Twitter.
Here's what drove Tesla
investors away in 2022,
and what's affecting the
car maker going into 2023.
Let's start with demand.
For years, Tesla has
stood out as the leader
in the electric vehicle space,
and while its dominance continued
in the third quarter of 2022,
its market share slipped to 61%.
- In the last year,
we've seen an explosion of
competing EV models for Tesla,
and as that number continues
to grow over the years,
the concern is whether or not demand
for Tesla vehicles will
continue to stay as high
as it has been in the past.
- [Narrator] According to JD Power,
there were 33 EV models
available in the US
at the end of 2021, but by the end of 2022
that number had jumped to 53 models.
Tesla still held four
of the top five selling
EVs last year according
to S&P Global Mobility.
But the sell-off in Tesla shares
reflects investors' fear
that its hold won't last
as newer models arrive.
- Tesla has sold the same
sort of handful of models
for years now, and the question is
will Tesla continue to be as competitive
as it has in the past or
will they become outdated?
- [Narrator] Further fueling concerns
are customer wait times for Tesla cars,
which dropped sharply over 2022.
Some investors see this as a sign
demand is already softening.
Musk addressed these concerns
on Tesla's third quarter earnings call.
- [Musk] I can't emphasize enough.
We have excellent demand for Q4,
and we expect to sell
every car that we make
as far into the future as we can see.
- [Narrator] And in December, the CEO said
on a Twitter Spaces call
that demand pressures
were driven by rising
interest rate policies.
Production disruptions also contributed
to the stock slide last year
leading to Tesla missing
its full year vehicle delivery target.
The EV makers said it
delivered 1.3 million vehicles
in 2022, up 40% from 2021.
That was shy of its goal
of increasing deliveries
by 50% or more.
It would've needed more than
1.4 million to hit that target.
News of the shortfall pushed stocks down
another 12% to start the new year.
Its largest single day decline
in more than two years.
Intermittent factory closures
at Tesla's China plant,
its largest by volume,
were one part of the problem.
- China's zero COVID policy led
to a number of shutdowns
at its factory in Shanghai,
which obviously created
supply issues of its own.
- [Narrator] Tesla also
faced issues at new factories
in Texas and Germany,
where it struggled to ramp up production.
Musk addressed those
problems in a May interview.
- Both Berlin and Austin factories
are gigantic money furnaces right now.
- [Narrator] Rising
supplier and logistics costs
combined with soaring inflation
contributed to these production setbacks.
- Tesla and every manufacturer
making EVs today is
confronting rapidly rising
costs from the raw materials
that go into the batteries,
to construction related costs
or frankly even labor related costs.
All of that is going up,
and the car industry is not
one with huge profit margins.
- [Narrator] For Tesla, this
included spending roughly
11 billion in the first quarter on items
needed to make and sell cars.
- Overwhelmingly, our concern is how do we
keep the factories operating
so we can pay people and not go bankrupt?
- [Narrator] Overvaluation is
another factor some investors
and analysts say is complicating
Tesla's shrinking stock price.
- Tesla has been egregiously overvalued
for the last couple years based on hype.
- [Narrator] At its peak,
Tesla was worth more
than the 10 largest automakers
on the planet combined
despite having just a
fraction of their sales.
- A lot of investors who
have debated whether or not
Tesla is an overvalued
company have done so
based on the fact that it
owned a huge percentage
of the US EV market
and that it was the first
mover in that market.
Its valuation was driven
in part by its CEO
and some investors say Musk's promises
about future vehicles
have pushed shares higher
though many of the cars
didn't come until years later.
The latest example, Tesla's cyber truck,
which was first unveiled three years ago
and still hasn't hit the market.
- Cyber truck is gonna be awesome.
It's worth the wait. Believe me.
- [Narrator] And more directly,
Musk's move to offload
billions in Tesla stock
in part related to Twitter,
has pushed down Tesla's share price.
- Anytime anybody sells $40
billion worth of company's stock
it's gonna bring that stock price down.
What isn't clear is how
that specific action
is influencing other investors.
- [Narrator] Tesla did not
respond to request for comment.
Tesla's stock selloff comes
as investors across the market
prepare for what some see
as an oncoming recession.
A downturn could slow car buying,
especially for pricier vehicles.
- Will those people who might
otherwise in 2022 or 2021,
purchase a $60,000 vehicle?
Will they instead purchase a
$40,000 gas powered vehicle?
- [Narrator] On Tesla's
third quarter earnings call,
Musk said that he sees the EV company
as recession resilient.
- [Musk] Let's say 2023 is
a brutal recession year.
Even then, we generate meaningful cash.
- [Narrator] Tesla investors
are now waiting for later
this month when the car maker will report
its full year earnings,
which could give a glimpse
of the stock's prospects
for the coming year.
(upbeat music)